[Musique]
en travaillant dans l'urbanisme
mon plus grand défi a toujours été de
raisonner en termes de développement
durable avec ma société je voulais
travailler dans le domaine de l'hygiène
des toilettes
mais comment aborder ce problème dans
une perspective différente en dehors de
la pensée traditionnelle sur ce sujet
alors on a imaginé les échos toilettes
des toilettes qui devait devenir un lieu
de développement social une sorte de
centre commercial des toilettes
[Musique]
nous sommes à nairobi la capitale du
kenya ici 75% de la population est
privée de systèmes sanitaires
alors depuis deux ans david surya
révolutionne en douceur le monde des
toilettes
c'est la première il côtoie lettre que
l'on a installé les gens l'ont
immédiatement adoptée et le gouvernement
a commencé à comprendre l'intérêt d'un
partenariat entre le secteur privé et le
secteur public pour améliorer l'aspect
sanitaire de nos villes les y côtoie
let's et du tout écolo
ici on utilise de l'eau de pluie filtré
par les rayons du soleil des toilettes
sèches sans aucun produit chimique et
aucun rejet d'excréments dans la nature
avec sa société
david curry a réussi là où les
municipalités ont échoué au kenya la
situation sanitaire est déplorable
les très rares toilettes publiques qui
existent sont un enfer sales puants
tenus par les gangs
elles sont le lieu d échange de drogue
de vols de viols et de crimes en tous
genres when we came up et des offres eco
quand on a eu l'idée des ics aux
toilettes il a fallu que l'on transforme
la perception que les gens avaient des
toilettes traditionnelle en et vision
plus moderne
on s'est appuyé sur trois axes la
sécurité que l'intimité et l'hygiène de
nos clients une autre chose importante
pour ces toilettes c'est que ce sont des
faits tout autour un grand nombre de
petites activités commerciales les
toilettes reviennent alors bien plus que
des toilettes elle vous offre d'autres
services cela par des toilettes et ça
devient un lieu de commerce et
d'interaction sociale à l'arrière vous
trouvez des cireurs de chaussures
il ya aussi des marchands ambulants
comme des vendeurs de glaces à l'eau ou
de maquillage pour les enfants c'était
ça notre idée penser au delà des
toilettes pour gagner notre combat sur
les toits les ide architecture soignée
petite boutique hygiène irréprochable
les kenyans adopte immédiatement ses
toilettes à 5 centimes d'euro l'entrée
en quelques semaines la société de david
kuria d'école en flèche au début pour
être rentable notre business plan
prévoyait 600 utilisateurs jours c'est
ce qui nous permettait d'être en
sécurité financière
mais aujourd'hui la toilette qui est ici
fait le double de ce qu'on espérait on y
enregistre 1200 clients par jour et
certaines toilettes font jusqu'à 10 fois
nos prévisions soit 5 à 6 mon client
jour et par toilettes en deux ans david
curien à gagner des prix obtenu une
reconnaissance internationale et a été
élu deux fois entrepreneur social
d'afrique
il a déjà installé 44e' qu'aux toilettes
à travers le pays la tanzanie et
l'ouganda
lyon aussi passer des commandes ces dix
dernières années j'ai travaillé pour le
gouvernement en tant qu'humaniste j'ai
essayé de promouvoir des concepts de
développement durable mais j'ai réalisé
que malgré les millions de dollars
investis on passait toujours à côté d'un
modèle de développement durable
chaque fois que je me promenais dans les
bidonvilles
j'essayais de comprendre pourquoi nous
n'étions pas parvenus à mettre en place
un système pérenne pourquoi ces
bidonvilles ne cesse de grandir
et un des principaux problèmes qui vous
frappe dans les bidonvilles c'est le
problème de l'urbanisme
il
[Musique]
voici les toilettes du bidonville qui
servent aussi de salle de bain le
problème majeur c'est qu'elle se vide
dans ces rigole à ciel ouvert qui se
déversent directement dans la rivière
et si vous descendez à la rivière vous
constaterez qu'elle ressemble à une
fosse septique
elle est totalement contaminés avec
l'argent récolté jusqu'ici
david surya se lancent alors un nouveau
défi inventé unique aux toilettes
spécifiquement adaptés aux bidonvilles
voici la première rico toile est mise
dans un bidonville
en ce moment on projette d'en installer
et dix de plus ici ce qui frère unique
aux toilettes pour quatre soirs famille
on espère que dans les cinq ans on aura
transformé ce bidonville en un lieu plus
hygiénique pour ses habitants dans ses
toilettes on a aussi installé des
douches
car ils n'ont pas ici
de l'eau propre une douche et des
toilettes à l'hygiène irréprochable plus
d'excréments qui s'écoule dans la
rivière une révolution au coeur du
bidonville
seul problème à 5 centimes par douches
pour les gens du ghetto c'est encore un
peu cher
on s'est aperçu rapidement qu'avec un
prix d'entrée à 5 centimes les parents
utilisaient volontiers les toilettes
mais il ne voulait pas payer pour leurs
enfants
donc on avait installé ses toilettes les
enfants eux continué à déféquer dans la
rue pour les encourager à utiliser les
toilettes
on a imaginé cette carte avec cette
carte
toute la famille peut utiliser les
toilettes pendant un mois quelle que
soit la taille de la famille d'une
petite famille à une famille très
nombreuse
vous ne payerez 15 euros par mois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aujourd'hui les échos toilettes sont
devenues un enjeu politique
chaque inauguration se transforme en
événement unique aux toilettes dans sa
ville
c'est la preuve qu'on se soucie de ses
administrés si vous regarder derrière
moi
regardez ce projet qui s'appelle ico
toilettes est un projet encore trop rare
dans ce pays
nous devons remercier les gens dit qu au
tac et son fondateur pour ce qu'il a
fait je m'associe aux marchands aux
petits commerçants et à tous les
citoyens de cette commune afin de le
remercier de nous aider à changer le
visage de nos villes en plus de
l'hygiène les icônes toilettes c'est
aussi 10 emplois supplémentaires pour
chaque établissement créé désormais
david curières reçu partout maires
gouverneurs ministre tout le monde veut
avoir unique aux toilettes dans sa ville
très heureuse de vous recevoir
mais david surya garde la tête froide
le business écolo au service des
déshérités reste sa principale
motivation et il n'est pas à court
d'idées
toute l'idée des ipos net est de créer
un processus écologique complet
donc on a essayé de trouver un moyen de
réutiliser la biomasse produite dans
chaque établissement
notre axe de développement principal qui
pourra devenir une grande source de
revenu c'est de faire du fertilisant
avec de lloris
pour l'instant nous pouvons collecter
500 millilitres du ring par mois dans
nos toilettes et comme nous développons
nous pourrons bientôt compter sur un
million de litres par mois
je vois de vraies opportunités pour le
business social car il va se concentrer
sur les millions de gens qui sont au bas
de la pyramide en les aidant à
développer leur potentiel
le futur de l'afrique repose sur le
business social il va faire éclore de
nouvelles idées pour répondre aux
besoins des sociétés it on n'est pas là
pour donner du poisson aux gens où leur
apprendre à pêcher
on est là pour changer toute l'industrie
de la pêche
[Musique]